[Aplausos]
[Música]
parece difícil complicado casi imposible
de creer dadas las circunstancias pero
hubo una época hace no mucho tiempo en
la que venezuela fue la envidia de toda
latinoamérica
[Música]
en este canal os hemos hablado mucho de
la venezuela de hoy os hemos contado que
está ocurriendo porque está ocurriendo e
incluso algunas de las cosas que pueden
llegar a pasar
y creo que hoy todos tenemos muy claro
lo que está pasando todo salvo íñigo
errejón lo cierto es que tras casi 20
años de revolución bolivariana venezuela
es un país destrozado un país que sufre
una brutal crisis económica la falta de
alimentos y medicinas y una inseguridad
galopante
algo que lógicamente ha provocado que
millones de venezolanos se hayan
marchado en busca de una vida mejor
venezuela atraviesa ni más ni menos que
una enorme crisis humanitaria sin
embargo he esperado un momento porque
esto no siempre fue así como os he dicho
hubo una época hace no tanto tiempo en
la que venezuela era un país próspero un
país al que muchas personas emigraban en
busca de oportunidades queréis conocer
mejor esta otra historia pues atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la venezuela prospera
bueno como seguro ya todos sabéis
venezuela tiene las mayores reservas
conocidas de petróleo convencional de
todo el planeta
hablamos de más de 300.000 millones de
barriles de petróleo si de mejor o peor
calidad
venezuela tiene más petróleo que toda
rusia o arabia saudita y no solo
petróleo también otros muchos muchísimos
recursos naturales venezuela es un país
muy rico que tiene de todo hierro
petróleo oro diamantes gas y una banda
de delincuentes los tomo el puma
rodríguez pues bien el caso es que hubo
un tiempo donde los venezolanos sí que
supieron sacar partido a toda esta
inmensa fortuna me estoy refiriendo a la
década de los 70
[Música]
[Aplausos]
veréis en aquel momento las cosas en
venezuela iban como decirlo en términos
marineros viento en popa ya toda vela
y van también las cosas que a los
turistas venezolanos se les conocía como
los dame dos porque entraban en las
tiendas y se llevaban de todo cuánto
vale eso la menos
[Música]
y es que amigos en aquellos años había
dinero y lo que es más importante se
ganaba dinero
de esta forma es como surgió una pujante
clase media el desempleo era de apenas
el 4% y cada año se construían miles y
miles de kilómetros de nuevas carreteras
la pobreza que hoy afecta a nueve de
cada diez venezolanos no superaba el 20
por ciento
eran tiempos felices había tantos
excesos que por ejemplo viajar a miami
se convirtió en algo habitual entre la
clase media
[Música]
y sabéis dónde estaban los mejores y más
caros restaurantes franceses de toda la
región
exacto en caracas y aún más los
venezolanos ojos se convirtieron ni más
ni menos que los mayores consumidores de
whisky de todo el mundo si habéis
escuchado bien en aquellos años parecía
que este país iba a comerse el mundo ya
sabéis cuánto vale eso
[Música]
de hecho por aquel entonces y a
diferencia de lo que ocurre hoy en día
venezuela se convirtió en toda una meca
para miles y miles de inmigrantes
latinoamericanos todo el mundo quería
experimentar la prosperidad venezolana
incluso gracias a un sistema democrático
que funcionaba venezuela se convirtió
también en un refugio para muchos
exiliados procedentes del chile de
pinochet o la argentina- de las juntas
militares
[Música]
sin embargo amigos de visual político es
evidente que un buen día toda esta
bonanza se terminó así que las dos
preguntas que podemos hacernos son como
logró venezuela ser un país tan próspero
y la segunda porque se terminó todo
pues bien veámoslo
petro venezuela
gracias a los recursos naturales a unas
instituciones que más o menos
funcionaban aunque si no era suiza y a
una población relativamente bien formada
venezuela fue tradicionalmente uno de
los países más prósperos de américa
latina' venezuela era tan rica como
noruega en los 60 sin embargo lo que
ocurrió a principios de los años 70 fue
mucho más allá os hago una pregunta o
suena de algo el año 1973
en octubre de ese año los países árabes
pertenecientes a la opep la organización
de países exportadores de petróleo
decidieron castigar a los países que
habían apoyado a israel en la guerra del
yom kippur
bueno a ver esta al menos fue la excusa
oficial pero también es cierto que estos
países llevaban años negociando con las
compañías de petróleo una fórmula para
incrementar los ingresos de estos países
y que las negociaciones no llegaron a
ninguna parte el caso es que sabéis que
se les ocurrió hacer ni más ni menos que
bloquear sus exportaciones de petróleo a
todos aquellos países que hubieran
apoyado a israel eso incluía a eeuu ya
gran parte de la europa occidental
para que nos entendamos esta acción fue
equivalente a un gran recorte en la
producción mundial de petróleo un
recorte que prácticamente de la noche a
la mañana golpeó al mercado mundial con
una fuerza descomunal el efecto fue
inmediato en poco tiempo el precio del
barril del petróleo pasó de
aproximadamente 1 con 60 dólares a casi
10 dólares de la noche a la mañana los
países productores de petróleo eran
ricos ricos de verdad
y ya lo sabéis en venezuela- otra cosa
no pero petróleo todo el que quieras
bueno ahora hay petróleo pero el
gobierno de maduro no es capaz de
extraerlo con lo cual es como si no lo
hubiera
[Música]
el caso es que este país fue uno de los
grandes beneficiados de la crisis del
petróleo del año 73 de repente no sólo
se había incrementado el precio sino que
además todas las potencias occidentales
se pegaban por el petróleo venezolano
[Música]
con el bloqueo de la opep había quedado
claro que venezuela era un proveedor
mucho muchísimo más seguro
e
de esta forma los petrodólares empezaron
a llover como si no hubiera mañana y en
1975 el presidente carlos andrés pérez
decidió nacionalizar todo el petróleo y
crear pedevesa
con ella desde ese momento la inmensa
mayor parte de la lluvia de petrodólares
fue a parar a las arcas del estado que
por supuesto también empezó a gastar
como si no hubiera mañana fueron los
años locos de venezuela en 1977 la renta
per cápita de este país prácticamente
duplicaba la del resto de américa
latina' caracas en una ciudad en
ebullición repleta de construcciones y
proyectos por todas partes
sin embargo he esperado un momento como
veis toda esta bonanza tuvo como causa
fundamental la enorme cantidad de
petrodólares que empezaron a llover
sobre venezuela venezuela fue un país
muy exitoso precisamente por la renta
petrolera hasta los años 70
esa renta le permitió al país financiar
la modernización de los servicios
humberto garcía larralde cuando un
gobierno empieza a recibir tanto dinero
de repente tiene dos opciones o gastarlo
como si no hubiera mañana o invertirlo
de forma seria y utilizarlo para
impulsar la economía nacional la
pregunta es qué pensáis qué hizo el
gobierno de venezuela atentos
[Música]
el fin del sueño
con toda la lluvia de dinero que produjo
el petróleo el entonces presidente de
venezuela carlos andrés pérez prometió
que el país se desarrollaría
completamente en pocos años pregunta
adivináis qué estrategia utilizó fijaos
[Música]
con el dinero del petróleo se puso en
marcha una política que apostó por
cerrar la economía venezolana poner
elevados aranceles y restringir la
competencia para así desarrollar una
industria local que fuera capaz de
sustituir las importaciones vamos lo que
vino a hacer la política de sustitución
de importaciones típica de américa
latina y que también conocida es por los
argentinos el populismo industrial
subiría lo podríamos conceptualizar como
aquella versión que pone a la
sustitución de importaciones en el
centro y la entronización de la política
económica la mesa está servida
esencialmente para la sustitución de
importaciones nos venden todo más caro
que afuera con el cuento de que si no
hay empleo
junto a ello el incremento del gasto
público que no dejó de crecer como la
espuma y los subsidios pagados con los
petrodólares ya sabéis había que ganar
elecciones serían el camino al
desarrollo
[Música]
el resultado de todo ello es que en poco
tiempo a hacer negocios con el estado o
tener un trato de favor por parte del
gobierno se convirtió en la actividad
más lucrativa de todo el país y eso es
algo que siempre conlleva tres problemas
primero la corrupción se dispara claro
si la forma de hacer dinero es influir
en la voluntad de un político o un
funcionario al final siempre acaban
apareciendo los sobres confundidos con
el pueblo primero en maracaibo y
posteriormente en triste
carlos andrés ratifica su promesa de
resolver desde el gobierno los problemas
de las clases populares
[Música]
segundo cuando el estado es la mayor
fuente de oportunidades negocios las
empresas se especializan en producir no
para los consumidores ni para el resto
del mundo sino en producir para el
estado y de la misma forma las empresas
que viven de tener el favor del gobierno
con una competencia restringida tampoco
son las más innovadoras y las más
eficientes al final genera un sistema
económico dependiente y poco productivo
y tercero todo esto implica que el
gobierno no puede parar de gastar de una
forma u otra todo se levanta sobre el
dinero público al final nunca queda ni
un centavo y si muchas deudas ahora con
cerrar la economía la competencia
importada y someter a los exportables a
un complejo esquema de retenciones y
provisiones puede portar no alcanza para
poder crecer sobre la base de la
sustitución es necesario darle demanda
darle gas y ahí aparece el gasto público
y el déficit fiscal a la larga los
déficit fiscales
eran situaciones de quiebre en cada
programa económico pues bien eso fue
exactamente lo que ocurrió en venezuela
cuando en la década de los 80 el precio
del petróleo empezó a bajar toda esa
prosperidad venezolana empezó también a
venirse abajo
[Música]
en 1983 cuando se produce el llamado
'viernes negro' el 18 de febrero el
bolívar se vino abajo respecto al dólar
fue un primer aviso pero el gobierno
hizo caso omiso siguió con sus planes
gastando a lo loco y favoreciendo a los
amiguetes del poder en 1989 y la cosa no
dio más de sí y la economía venezolana
sufrió una enorme crisis
fue entonces cuando se produjo el
llamado caracazo una oleada de protestas
contra el gobierno que derivó en saqueos
y enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad del estado que no dudaron en
utilizar la fuerza de una forma
totalmente indiscriminada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el resultado pone los pelos de punta
según los datos oficiales se perdieron
276 vidas algunos datos extraoficiales
hablan de cerca de 3000 venezuela había
comenzado su carrera hacia el abismo
[Música]
en fin amigos como veis la fortuna de
los recursos naturales puede convertirse
con malos gobiernos en la peor de las
pesadillas venezuela tuvo la oportunidad
de convertirse en un país tremendamente
rico desgraciadamente no cogió el tren y
hoy ya conocemos el resultado si te ha
resultado interesante este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscríbete aviso al polític si aún no lo
has hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
nos venden todo más caro que fuera con
el cuento de siempre 9 que hay mami ayer
en united states and there is down hill
en 3 huevos
[Música]